c'est là qu'il est il fait toujours très
chaud à rio de janeiro
ouais c'est pierre qui a écrit cette
chanson donc là les trois là les trois
ont fini les missions en soule 10 ans
atteint c'est très simple je vous posais
une question pour donner la réponse même
ben laurie même pierre si vous avez la
réponse
il faudra se lever et faire une petite
salle à cordes ok vous voulez faire un
petit dc oui non et n'a pas peur
j'espère que je sens que jean-luc ne va
pas répondre j'ai le démon de la danse
en moi va nous surprendre
pourquoi l'émission enquête d'action sur
les analystes at elle été pointé du
doigt les journalistes ont agressé des
manifestants ils ont recycler un vieux
reportage de m6 ils ont oublié de
flouter des témoins sous les analystes
étaient des comédiens qui ne s'était pas
lavé depuis trois ans alors alors
attention à ces merdes ans est allé
castaldi attention
[Musique]
une salsa sans tarder flamenco ça c'est
ça c'est l'expression de badens à moi
qu'aller au prince charmant c'est quoi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je crois une grande décision il ya que
qualité labo de saison elle est tombée
le trésor va tomber le très très haut la
wii en fait c'est vrai ils ont recycler
un vieux reportage de m6 alors hier ça a
été oh là là tout le monde a dit mais
qu'est ce que c'est que ça mais moi que
ça punk to you
pourquoi christine angot a fait encore
parler d'elle ce week-end elle a
démissionné
doc gynéco a balancé des anecdotes
coquine sur leur relation laurent
ruquier a révélé ses craintes ses
caprices ou en pleine émission à la
dévorer deux invités dont et patata
kelly danser danser
ouais la sépaq elie semoun crédit et la
personne en fait c'est kelly et la
personne alors ma venue à l'egba kelly
merci merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais naim c'est là on le dit latino elle
est obligée de faire de la danse
orientale sur ma vie mes narines sans
essai a récompensé à tajine ambulants
offraient alors abena et bien d'autres
sinequa balancer des anecdotes coquine
sur leur relation exactement quelles
informations chiffrées tyrannie
souvient-il de dévoiler l'âge de sa
première expérience sexuelle
le prix de vente de salut les terriens
son salaire ou le diamètre des boules de
thierry beccaro danois alors il faut
danser danser oui je sais pas parce
qu'elle y aille maximum
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci et bravo maxime bien c'est celui
qui a fait la meilleure danse
il n'avait même pas besoin de dollars il
s'agit du salaire de thierry ardisson
oui c'est un sommet du 20 mai les choix